hydrochloric acid is an example of a
strong acid and sodium hydroxide is an
example of a strong base when an aqueous
solution of hydrochloric acid reacts
with an aqueous solution of sodium
hydroxide the products are an aqueous
solution of sodium chloride and water
since the reaction goes to completion
instead of an equilibrium arrow there's
just an arrow going to the right and
this is called an acid-base
neutralization reaction let's think
about the ions that are involved in this
acid-base neutralization reaction since
hydrochloric acid is a strong acid hcl
ionizes 100 percent in solution and
therefore in solution hcl consists of h
plus ions and cl minus anions sodium
hydroxide is a strong base and strong
bases dissociate 100 percent in solution
therefore an aqueous solution of sodium
hydroxide consists of sodium ions and a
plus and hydroxide anions o h minus
for our product sodium chloride is a
soluble salt and therefore forms an
aqueous solution so in solution we would
have sodium cations n a plus and
chloride anions cl minus
since water ionizes only to a very small
extent we don't write it as the ions we
simply write h2o
to save some time i went ahead and added
an aqueous subscripts and for water it'd
be liquid and some plus signs and the
reaction arrow this is called the
overall ionic equation for our strong
acid strong base reaction
instead of calling it an overall ionic
equation we could also call it a
complete ionic equation and we can use
the overall ionic equation to determine
the net ionic equation for this strong
acid strong base reaction to figure out
the net ionic equation we first need to
determine the spectator ions remember
spectator ions don't participate in the
chemical reaction
notice how we have a sodium cation on
the reactant side and a sodium cation on
the product side so we can cancel out
the sodium cation we also have a
chloride anion on the reactant side and
a chloride anion on the product side so
we can cross that ion out as well so the
sodium cation and the chloride anion are
the spectator ions
and once we take out our spectator ions
we're left with the net ionic equation
so for the net ionic equation we would
have h plus
plus oh minus yields h2o
so this is one way of writing our net
ionic equation
however remember that h plus and h3o
plus are used interchangeably in
chemistry so instead of writing h plus
in our net ionic equation we could have
also written h3o plus and when h3o plus
or the hydronium ion reacts with the
hydroxide anion we still form water but
notice for this version of the net ionic
equation we need to put a 2 as a
coefficient to balance everything
next let's think about a situation where
we have equal moles of our strong acid
and strong base
for example let's say we have one mole
of hcl
and one mole of naoh to help us think
about what's happening in this situation
we're going to use an icf table where i
stands for the initial number of moles c
stands for the change in moles and f
stands for the final amount of moles
the reason why we're using an icf table
instead of an ice table is an ice table
the e stands for equilibrium and here we
assume the reaction goes to completion
therefore instead of e we're writing f
for final amount of moles
let's fill out the rest of our icf table
we have the initial amount of moles of
hcl and naoh and if we assume the
reaction hasn't happened yet the initial
amount of moles of nacl would be zero
looking at the balanced equation one
mole of hcl reacts with one mole of
sodium hydroxide and since the reaction
goes to completion we can go ahead and
write under the change part here we're
going to react one mole of hcl so we're
going to lose that one mole of hcl and
since it's a one to one ratio we're
going to lose one mole of naoh
and since there's a one as a coefficient
in front of nacl under the change part
on our icf table we would write plus one
mole for nacl
since we started with one mole of hcl
and we lost one mole the final amount of
moles for hcl would be zero same thing
for sodium hydroxide the final amount of
moles would be zero because it's one
minus one for nacl we started off with
zero and we gained one so we're ending
up with a final amount of moles of one
mole of sodium chloride so when the
reaction goes to completion the strong
acid and the strong base have completely
neutralized each other and essentially
we have an aqueous solution of sodium
chloride
at 25 degrees celsius the ph of water is
7 which is neutral
and the sodium cations and the chloride
anions do not react with water so they
don't affect the ph
therefore for the situation where you
have equal amount of moles of a strong
acid and strong base the ph of the
resulting solution will be 7.
let's do another strong acid strong base
calculation however this time the moles
of strong acid and strong base are not
equal
so let's say we react 300 milliliters of
a 1.0 molar solution of hcl
with 100 milliliters of a 1.0 molar
solution of sodium hydroxide and our
goal is to calculate the ph of the
resulting solution
and i should point out these are aqueous
solutions of hcl and naoh
the first step is to calculate moles of
strong acid and moles of strong base and
the equation for molarity is equal to
moles over liters so for our strong acid
hcl the molarity is 1.0
and the volume is 300 milliliters which
is equal to 0.300
liters so solving for x we find that x
is equal to 0.30 moles of hcl
for our strong base sodium hydroxide the
concentration is 1 molar and the volume
is 100 milliliters which is equal to
0.100 liters so solving for x we find
that x is equal to 0.10 moles of naoh
going back to hcl since hcl is a strong
acid that ionizes 100 percent if we have
0.30 moles of hcl we have 0.30 moles of
h plus ions or we could say
0.30 moles of hydronium ions h3o plus
and for sodium hydroxide since sodium
hydroxide is a strong base that
dissociates one hundred percent if we
have point one zero moles of sodium
hydroxide we have 0.10 moles of sodium
ions and also
0.10 moles
of hydroxide ions o h minus
and if we think about our net ionic
equation the 0.30 moles of hydronium
ions will react with the 0.10 moles of
hydroxide ions
so here's one way to write our net ionic
equation the hydronium ion plus the
hydroxide ion forms 2 h2o
and to help us find the ph we're going
to use another icf table
the initial moles of hydronium ions we
calculated to be 0.30
and then the initial moles of hydroxide
ions we calculated to be 0.10
because we don't have equal amounts of
moles and the mole ratio is one to one
in this case we're going to have a
limiting reactant and an excess reactant
since we only have .10 moles of
hydroxide ions all of the hydroxide ions
will react and since it's a 1 to 1 mole
ratio 0.10 moles of hydroxide ions will
react with 0.10 moles of hydronium ions
so we can write minus 0.10 under
hydronium as well
therefore when the reaction goes to
completion for the hydroxide ions we'll
have used all of them up we start with
0.10 and we're using up 0.10 therefore
we'll have 0 moles for the hydronium ion
we started with 0.30 moles minus 0.10
gives us
.20 moles so the hydroxide ions were our
limiting reactant and the hydronium ions
were our excess reactant
so the strong base neutralized some of
the strong acid that was present and we
can calculate the ph of the resulting
solution by the number of moles of
excess hydronium ions next we calculate
the concentration of hydronium ions in
solution since the number of moles of
hydronium ions is 0.20 we plug that into
our equation for molarity so molarity is
equal to moles over liters and the total
volume of our solution would be 300
milliliters plus 100 milliliters which
is 400 milliliters or
0.400 liters so let me go and write this
in here so 0.20 moles divided by 0.400
liters is equal to a concentration of
0.50 molar
and because the ph is equal to the
negative log of the concentration of
hydronium ions if we plug in our
concentration of hydronium ions at 0.50
the ph is equal to the negative log of
0.50 which is equal to
0.30
having a low ph for our resulting
solution at 25 degrees celsius makes a
lot of sense because we ended up with an
excess of acid